our opening face off brought to you by Simpson
Chevrolet we're underway as the cats swing it
around the boards into the Anaheim Zone bouncing
Puck came right through the crease and taking a
poke at it with Sam Bennett unable to get
it past Gibson around the boards though
they keep the pressure on and there they come
the defenseman down the boards to keep Pucks
in Mika chases it all the way behind the
net the big man all 6' five of him carries
the puck around the end Zone and now the cycle
begins back to Nik Mika whose Long wrist shot
is punched to the corner by Gibson Mika sends
it right back for kachuck who can't take it
off the top of the shelf and banine and able to
get just enough Out Center Ice ducks go for a
change as the Panthers bring it right back in
it's Bennett with a shot that's gloved off by
Gibson aggressively outside the top of his crease
to make that stop Sam Bennett can fire it he was
looking top corner and Gibson just flashed is
the leather makes a real good tonight number
1,7 83 rad kudas who was part of that team that
went to the final a year ago from the neutral zone
jackon M Nifty little move in the neutral zone
and he gains the line on his back hand tries to
throw it in front what a save by stolar as stro
came in on the back door on the attack and watch
the little move here at the blue line goes great
around ler Ryan and and he backhands his puck out
to the top of the crease Ryan Str hammered
it couldn't Elevate the puck and stoar did
a good job get now Alex color nice pass ahead to
Troy Terry and he'll at least bring it to Center
Ice as he tries to nudge it back to Henry gets a
little out of his reach quick counter and kachuck
drops it off shot off the wing is handled by The
Stick of Gibson and he said if you give barov any
space whatsoever in the offensive zone he will
make you pay a big key tonight stay tight to him
panan shot gloved off by stolar to support that
hazy short passes on the right side of the Zone
once again it's Fowler out High vrono just
outside the dot back to Fowler looking for
an opening shot punched Away by stars and the
rebound is backhanded just across the line by
Mika nudges it away from Sam Bennett got it to the
line Mika kept it in looking around Matthew kachuk
took the look over the shoulder made a pass
and a high shot off of Gibson goes in behind
the net the Chuck coming off backto Back 40 goal
campaigns and 100 Point Seasons always prominent
whenever you play these Florida Panthers Puck is
onside off a stick and silverberg got a lot on it
good stop by stolar and he trips up Nick Cousins
play goes on as Jones comes over to the line now
lbushkin sends it left side and there's a good
save with the blocker by stolar on a hard shot
from mikov who step stepped up stopped by Gibson
out of the line that one didn't get through and
this one off the shoulder of Gibson as they try
to go high short side it comes through the crease
about six players in the blue paint but the puck
comes across and out you know on the same side
that the puck is on with that defenseman pinching
down the wall it's going to help him keep more
Pucks in the offensive zone mome brings it right
through the logo servs it over on the right side
and patrono just quickly Threw It on net guys
veteran guys doing the exactly the same thing
that I'm doing and they don't get kicked out
yeah the rookie treatment right we we watched
Mason McTavish go through it here kulakov still
Deep In the Zone and gutus bounces it to the
line and just out as cousins Retreats with it
londell calling for it gets the pass through the
middle and luster Ran's shot is disrupted wide
off the Stick of gutus leran giv go brings it
back in front and scores Nifty looking play the
Panthers have broken the ice and take the lead
yeah londell what a pass from behind the net
because you got to turn your head around and
watch this play from behind the net lcer rhan is
going to get it right back and he's got a little
room on that short side but the key is that quick
one-touch pass coming back in his Direction ad ver
hay step in front of him Al vergy turns gets
it on net there's a 40 goal scorer a year ago
and he's got the puck as he recovers the rebound
manages just to keep Pucks in a little bit deep
ER and this is a forward group that does a real
good job of protecting Puck down low they don't
give it away easily but finds a little room
before he's checked by loc terine and cousins
gets it back pass across and egman Larson off the
post and in wow what a shift by the Panthers and
they are rewarded Oliver emman Larson's fifth of
the Year already and he has looked well he was a
member of the Vancouver kucks for example he looks
like he's found a home because very comfortable
as he sneaks down off that left Point nobody
can get a stick on him and uh you know makes
a perfect shot you know just over the glove and
silverberg has to go off the boards and out Jones
on it pulls up nice pass across into the front
of the net lushin and it poked Away by stolar
made by mikov here just feathers it out front and
there's the touch by labush so it's defenseman
to defense partner right on top of the goal
crease and Anthony stolar misses with the Poke
check he got that on the inside of the right
leg and he's trying to get a little feeling
back penalty is over stro behind the defense
in Glu save and then a pass save on the rebound
by stolar oh my and then as he comes out of the
Penalty Box Ryan stroes in alone good stop on the
initial save better one on the rebound watch him
lunge with that left toe and Panthers right to the
go mouth backand chance rebound reaching for it
was BAGI and somehow Gibson kept it out now Sasha
barov he walks in from the dot goes to the back
hand that's a great save with the left leg and the
The Rebound with one hand is going to be tapped
back towards Veri tries to slide it over the line
Gibson just kind of Dives across with that catch
glove makes a real good stop keeps the ducks in
this game and eventually they were able to come
up with the turnover pass through the middle of
the ice broken up here's a short-handed bid Henrik
comes in goes backand stolar got a piece of the
glove on it short-handed bid and a real nice
play right here for Adam Henrik watch him go
to the backand he drags it a long way but those
long legs of Anthony stolar is able to cut it
off Henri's in pretty tight and when when you're
in that tight up the middle of the ice as he got
enough left in the tank to beat mour to the net he
got a one-handed backhander on net and a good stop
by stars Fowler keeps it in and throws it deep
that's going to do it the penalty to leushin is
over entry a little clunky at the line but vrono
rescues it to stro and he'll throw it back to him
now the Ducks are set up Fowler across the
top WI fires tip star's made the save it's
loose behind him stroes behind him as well but
the puck isn't now Fowler winds and fires again
blocked by londell recovered by vrono Henri oh
fat rebound score Frank vrono there you [Music]
go and we talk about it all the time those cor
Trot boy that's so close on the first Jam as
stron gets out of that goal crease the Ducks
do a good job of recoveries it was vrono that
kept it alive and it was vrono who was able to
mop it up and bring Anaheim back within a goal
so and it's sticked Away by stard clearing
intercepted by Carrick and off the end board
silverberg stucks it on the wrap around and stolar
got to the near post oh boy long leg that left pad
again quick move goes to the backand oh they
took a long look at it the referee was right
there yeah you know what that's close John that
is real close the puck was up on edge and if so
it might have gotten across I think it's in I
think that baby's in well I think you got about
four and that's going to do it but Toronto
back to get it in his own Zone can't settle
it throws it ahead stolar steers it away and
they continue to boo at Honda Center because
this is unpopular they think they should be
going to overtime but instead it's a 2-1 win